most americans deeply sympathize with
the people of ukraine they got invaded
who wouldn't sympathize with them
so our congress and our executive branch
have been busy shoveling armaments to
the government of ukraine and again
no one's questioning anyone's motives
here but if you're going to accelerate a
conflict in eastern europe
you have to wonder what the consequences
might be what would it mean if the
united states was sucked into a war with
russia
well that's one of the questions we
asked the other day to congresswoman
maria salazar of florida she's the one
who refused to rule out imposing a
no-fly zone over ukraine in fact called
for it watch
my position is
that we should not take not the no-fly
zone off the table but before that
that's two we need to do one and one is
to give zelinski exactly what he's
asking for no troops on the ground let's
give him the mix and the s-300 what he
needs to defend his own air
airspace so he will create his no his
own no-fly zone
so if you're starting to get the
impression that the people formulating
our foreign policy have no freaking clue
what they're talking about and haven't
thought past say tonight in the
implications of what they're
recommending
you may be on to something there are a
lot of deeply ignorant reckless people
even some of them motivated by perfectly
noble impulses
who are running things
so may now may be the time to pause and
ask what would it mean to enter into a
hot war with russia
brian dean wright is a former cia
operations officer he's thought a lot
about that he joins us tonight brian
thanks so much for coming on
so
this is one of those questions i mean
look i think the public has a right to
determine what it thinks of this and
make that decision on the basis of all
available facts so i'd just be
interested
in asking what you think
how close are we to
an open war with russia and what would
that mean for the united states
great questions it gets worse every day
the possibility of a hot war are real
and getting more real every day look
what i'm asking americans to do tonight
is put aside their hatred for putin or
zielinski for that matter or ukraine or
russia put all that aside for a moment
understand that we have in effect
declared war against russia we have done
three things one we have crippled their
economy right two we are shoving in all
these weapons and third this hasn't
gotten a lot of press we are giving
tactical intelligence to the ukrainian
government to put an x on the forehead
of a russian soldier and russian
equipment
let me say that a little differently
our spies and our satellites are helping
the ukrainians kill russians so we have
declared war so we should be asking
shouldn't we what's that war going to
look like to your point and indeed we
should start with the first place of
well who's actually putting together our
war response
well we know that the folks of the
pentagon are the ones who are primarily
responsible for that but but actually
wait a second
they just got us out of a 20-year war
didn't they or actually they kept us in
one and we lost it
yeah to goat herders
okay now we have folks on capitol hill
in the white house who were also around
for 20 years and they were those who
were formulating the policies that also
lost that war
so the people who are now formulating
our response to a nuclear-armed russia
or the same ones who couldn't figure out
how to beat goat herders in afghanistan
that should cause everyone a very real
degree of concern and we should be
asking each other about it and we should
be talking about it so then the second
question becomes if in fact this gets
hot what happens we know that it will
escalate and so that means some of the
first steps will be what are called
asymmetric right russia can't sanction
our economy in the way that we did his
so he's going to do things like a cyber
attack i want people to ask themselves
tonight what if in their hometown russia
were to shut off the lights or the water
do you think there might be riots
probably
you brought forward this very horrific
idea and notion tonight in brooklyn
other places of breadlines you think
that could get violent of course it
could
so how would people's mayors and
governors respond to riots we saw a
couple years ago does that give you a
pause seen the blm riots that should
also give you a quote so we have a whole
variety of issues about then the
sacrifice that will go on that's a whole
different segment but it involves young
people dying and we should also be
talking about that because our people in
washington aren't going to be the ones
sacrificing
but they are the ones who feel virtuous
by doing all of this stuff and damn the
consequences i see i see a pattern a
recurring theme here
um and i'm just grateful for the clarity
you provided brian dean right i hope
you'll come back
thank you you bet hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else